Welcome to the third
week of our course
on shaping the future of work.
Now that we've laid the
historical foundation
by looking at what made
the social contract
work in our countries
in the past,
it's time to start to lay out
a framework for the future.
So this week we're going to pay
special attention to the time
when we first began to identify
what made for high road
firms versus low road firms.
Remember the diagram that
we had in the first chapter
of the book that we are
reading for this course, where
we identified what
differentiates firms that
are perhaps good
for shareholders
and produce good
financial results, but not
such good results for workers
compared to those that
produce good results for both?
We're going to try to
understand what makes
these different firms work.
And we're going to see if
we can identify how we can
use these ideas in the future.
Now when we look at
these organizations--
and we'll bring in examples
like Market Basket, Patagonia,
Ideal, Saturn, Costco,
Southwest Airlines, and others--
we're not doing that to
put these organizations
on a pedestal, but really
to dig deeply to understand
what makes them
work, and how can we
apply these in the industries
and organizations of interest
to us.
And to do that we're going to
really focus on two objectives
this week.
One is just what I said,
what are the ingredients
of these high road firms?
And then, how might we
use this understanding
to decide whether or
not we want to work
for an employer that has some
of these characteristics?
We'll do that by applying
a tool that you'll
find in the Assignment
tab of the course.
It's called the
Good Jobs Survey.
And it asks you to go out,
find a firm of interest
to you or in an
industry that you
may have a particular
interest in working in,
and talk to someone.
Talk to an employee
in that firm.
Ask them about the
conditions of work
that are present in
that organization.
You'll find a rating form.
You can fill out the form.
Then you provide your answers
on the platform for the course.
And down the road, we
will report what everyone
learned from that experience.
We want you to remember
these ideas though,
because we'll use them
throughout the rest
of the course.
Particularly, we're
going to put them
to work when we come to the
grand finale of this course,
where we negotiate a new social
contract, the next generation's
social contract.
Governing conditions of
employment in our workplace
is the future.
So we want you to
use some of the ideas
that you learned from
both the Good Jobs Survey,
but also from observing
and learning about some
of the organizations
that have good practices
that we can then apply
in our own organizations.
So that's a good deal of
what we will do this week.
And I hope that you will have
a good time with the materials
and that you'll have a good time
applying them as we go forward.
But I'd like to make two quick
comments on what we learned
from last week's discussion.
I was particularly
impressed with the sample
of organizations
that you identified
as you went through your
career planning exercise.
A wide array of very
interesting jobs,
from engineering, clergy
members, disability teachers,
HR managers, labor leaders,
artists, sports agents--
for the National Football
League, no less--
psychometricians, people
who use mathematics
to try to understand how to
measure individual behavior
and attitudes, futurists,
graphic artists,
technical editors.
Note that all of these
are jobs that really
are going to require
considerable human touch,
creativity, and effort.
None of these are going
to be totally replaced
by robots, or artificial
intelligence, or machine
learning.
And so I don't want
you to be too scared
about the future of work.
I want you to prepare for it.
That's what we're
learning from this course.
That's what we're learning
from this particular exercise.
So put the pathways
of education that you
identified in the career
planning exercise to work.
Do your part to be
prepared for the future.
And then work with us and
with other stakeholders
to make sure that
the conditions are
present to make it successful.
I was also very
interested to learn
what you had to say about the
great debate over productivity
and wages.
You completed a poll.
And here's the
results of that poll.
85% of you agreed that
wages and productivity
ought to move together.
About 7%, 7.5%, said you're
not sure, and another 7%
said, well maybe not anymore.
In fact, many of you
indicated while you believe
in this principle,
you believe it's also
going to be difficult to apply
it in the current economy given
changes in technology, changes
in international competition,
and the way in which
organizations are structured
today.
But I believe there are ways
we can apply these concepts.
But we have to do
it in ways that
are consistent with the economy
and the workforce today.
So I've added some more
comments on the discussion board
about how we can apply
productivity and wage
movements at the national level,
at the organizational level,
even at the individual level.
So take a look.
Keep that great
discussion going.
And let's see what
we can do to apply
this concept appropriately
in the economy today
and in the jobs of the future.
And finally, there are going
to be some new ideas raised
by our MBA TAs as
they contribute
from their own
knowledge and experience
base from around the
world, and from some
of our special
experts that we will
introduce into the
course on topics
as we go forward this week.
So have a good time.
Engage the materials.
And let's keep a good
conversation going.